the left wants you to think that they
have a corner on compassion they don't
they're not capable of it because
they're followers and they're weak I
want to sort of go back to where we're
talking what left the culture at large
but apply it to everyone listening you
know we kind of do this at the end of
the end of the show how does this apply
to you because a lot of it is one thing
Jordan Peterson has really tapped into
and I'm very very fortunate to have this
platform that we do but I think one of
the greatest evils today so let me start
with this and I see it from the left
almost exclusively is they've been
grained it into people with a brilliant
break bait-and-switch by the way um they
they equate envy with empathy and this
is one thing I actually disagree with a
lot of intellectuals out there on the
right is this idea that the left has a
general strong hold on compassion and
that the right has a majority stake in
industriousness or productivity that the
left is compassionate to the weak that
the right is is is cold and sort of
hell-bent on survival you know survival
of the fittest right the strength this
is a strong survive conquering a lot of
people on the right sort of concede this
it's a lie it's a lie I do not agree
with it at all
I see modern progressive leftists as the
least compassionate people potentially
in in modern society potentially in non
modern society when it comes to
comparing it to other societies who if
you leave feeling are the people who are
burning people alive I'm relatively
progressive I know people think that's
because words don't make sense anymore
but what drives the left today isn't
compassionate it really isn't it's
tapping into envy we see it from
everything from the proposed tax plans
and their slogans of eat the rich to the
way they score children's soccer games
namely in that they don't they don't
score them at all this is one thing too
I hear eat the rich we you can see these
on bumper stickers you see these with
the antiphon members you can see these
these slogans on flex you don't want to
eat the rich because you're
compassionate it's because you're
envious no one has a sign out there no
one has a three piece rocker that says
eat the rich because they're
compassionate people they didn't say how
can I help my fellow man eat the rich
it's because you're an envious little
bastard or [ __ ] we don't want to be
sexist here hashtag you do inclusive you
don't refuse to keep scores for children
sports not because it's compassion
we do it to cater to envy children will
envy the other team til Andy with the
other team has whether it's points on
the board or oranges at the halftime I
don't know if soccer has halftime I
don't fall in I'm not I'm not I'm not a
three-year-old girl or homosexual from
Greece to here Nick DiPaolo sales so
right you're the thing that this is what
really bothers me and then we'll get
into how it applies to your life rather
than be compassionate to the team who's
earned their stick who's earned their
keep you steal their victory you steal
their points and you hand it to the
envious that's not compassion to me that
is simply a political ploy to tap into
envy people screaming eat the rich are
not compassionate they're selfish people
the middle class is another thing there
was a study that came out recently I
heard it discussed will probably talk
about it next within the show it's not
disappearing I hear this a lot they said
well I love with $15 they did it in
Australia and they're okay $15 an hour
they did a living wage and this this
country or pick whatever province
whatever just take your pick
and so worked there it didn't implode
well on a second I in charge of the
world's National Defense also uh we have
the highest average income outside of
Luxembourg which is really basically a
tax haven so would you rather be the
society where we have a ton of people
with zero skills making $15 an hour or
would you rather be society where people
who did go to college who did learn a
skill or trade have the highest average
income what's more compassionate the
middle class is not disappearing but
there is some truth to when the left
says that the middle class most of you
watching middle-class you're often left
behind you know what that happens when
we create policies predicated on envy
Obamacare great example poor people got
subsidized health care because they
wanted it and couldn't afford it namely
most of them weren't working productive
members of society some of them not even
legal citizens you know got hit the
hardest not the wealthy they can always
afford it right but the middle class the
middle class who weren't such screw-ups
that they qualified for the subsidy and
they weren't wealthy enough to afford
the skyrocketing costs to subsidize the
premiums the skyrocketing deductibles
there's an irony for you that's not
compassion that's stealing from the
working middle class and yes the working
wealthy class I don't care if you're
wealthy or middle-class I think I care
that you're working I care that you're a
productive member of society and I want
reap the spoils of your work we took it
from them we gave it into the hands of
the people who are any envious Fannie
Mae Freddie Mac listen to that sub
brought me a subprime low market
predatory lending your debt predatory
lending let's go hey hey kid
come over here you want a giant sum of
cash that I know I'll never get back
I've got him right where I want him what
happened with this who got screwed it's
a middle class the housing crisis people
talked about skyrocketing home costs at
this point in society yeah it's true
that's also because homes are twice as
big
by the way when people talk about
skyrocketing home costs your house is on
average twice as big as a grandparents
house but I digress but guess what the
middle-class Americans who responsibly
saved 20 to 30 percent down for down
payment and they diligently built good
credit they didn't need the subprime
loans which the government was
effectively enforcing right when people
say predatory lending no one no one
lends money knowing that they won't get
it back they only do it when the
government forces them to make that loan
and of course backs it then it's free
money on the table but guess what the
middle class the people who responsibly
saved and scraped and lived diligently
they didn't need the subprime loans who
did the people who saved nothing the
people who had no credit the same people
who were envious of those who did the
exact opposite of them and when housing
crash happened and the envious covetous
old sinner --zz were a year late on all
of their housing payments and the
middle-class Americans by the way who
had scraped and saved and were ready for
the market to rebalance at that point to
finally buy their home hey I've got
money down hey I've saved up and that
the housing market was not furthered to
me so I rent it for a little bit but
here's my time the government said no
and the people who had no business being
in those houses made out like bandits
was that compassion no it was catering
to envy and so this is one thing that
really bothered you know what breeds
envy by the way weakness weakness breeds
envy weakness also breeds on
trustworthiness and breeds betrayal the
left loves too this is the thing they
want to vilify the strong is toxic
let me ask you how many time we've
talked about this latter we told it all
last week was Gavin McGinnis how many
times have you been betrayed by a strong
man or woman how many times have you
been backstabbed by the person your life
of the backbone the person is a little
tough to get along with in your life but
gets things done
how often have they screwed you
let's contrast think about the person
and we all know this person who just
never gets their crap together their
finances their marriages their
relationships the holding down of a job
they're in a constant state of crisis I
know these people they leave everyone
else holding the bag have they screwed
you over and maybe even if not are they
the person you would call to pick up
your kids are they the person you turn
to when you really need someone to trust
it is the weak among us who hurt us the
most and it doesn't mean that the strong
cannot be compassionate to the weak but
this idea that solely because people are
weak and I'm not just talking about your
benchpress I'm talking about weak of
character this idea that it weakness
exclusively means worthy of compassion
and strength means you don't need it
it's a lie it's a lie and and it's not
the Conservatives aren't compassionate
it's that we don't buy into that lie and
here's the thing if the progressive left
wants to build a society that caters to
weak people to the weak and more
specifically to the week's envy the left
they not only want a society they don't
want a society where strength can grow
right this is what we're talking about
this is what we ultimately we talked
about this we talk about the underdog
theory that why do they why do they love
Hamas when it's in their charter to kill
all Jews because they suck right because
they're weak because they're not very
good and so all right we're gonna go
with must they must be in the moral
superior must have the moral high ground
here but they want society to be
entirely dedicated that dictated
entirely dedicated to and dictated by
the squeezing wrenching grasping
scraping clutching covetous old sinner
'he's the people who say I can't afford
the house but I deserve it
yeah you know what III actually I didn't
score any goals but I feel that I
deserved that score so could you please
even it out you know what I never went
to college yeah I never much I didn't go
to trade school but I think I deserve 15
dollars an hour yeah you know what I I
didn't I didn't actually purchase
insurance before I got sick I did not
save up any money and I believed like
free health care please now in contrast
strength strength is important to know
not all strong people are good I'm not
saying that strength can breed
selfishness it can breed they can breed
bullishness but it can also breed
generosity weakness by its very
definition is incapable of breeding
generosity the weak cannot be generous
even if they wanted to hear that
socialist democratic socialist it
doesn't matter
it's not even on their radar there's
busy getting theirs they are they don't
even often have a second to think about
how to help others it's why food banks
go into poor neighborhoods not out of
them of course I understand it's a money
issue right I understand that people
with money are trying to how people do
my money but it's just a good example
right there if that's how you reacted
and you said my UC class and problems
entirely determined by money before
might not be able to donate their money
okay let me give an example but how
often do you see them critic nonprofit
efforts to meaning the weak among us
people who might be down and elec
financially but we all will give what we
can right how often you hear this in in
natural disasters give what you can
how often do you see poor people
creating nonprofits in an effort to I
don't know offer free marriage
counseling services help with the opioid
crisis among middle class use I can't
member who said this recently I don't
remember who it was it's gonna bother me
but someone can probably comment and let
me know someone said just because
somebody lives in a pretty house it
doesn't mean that pretty things go on
inside of them I think it's what this
person says I'm probably butchering the
quote that really stuck with me but the
weak can't be generous they're incapable
of it but the strong at least they can
sit back they can decide what to use
their strengths for good or bad and this
is what I want to see this is ultimately
what this comes down to I want to see
more strong people out there if you're
watching the show if you're listening
and you're not doing something to become
stronger every day you're doing it wrong
and I'm not asking for people out there
to be Heymann all I'm asking is that
you're stronger today than you were
yesterday that you'll be stronger
tomorrow than you were today that'll be
by a conscious effort I'm talking
physically emotionally intellectually
spiritually every day you better be
getting stronger because the only way
this world stays on track the only way
this will get saved is by the strong
among us using their strength to do
right so when I say that I don't have
any time for weakness it's not for a
lack of compassion and I hate it when
people concede that territory no I think
the Conservatives are the most
compassionate among us because we want
to create an atmosphere that fosters
strength which we knows we know breeds
life as opposed to sucks it from
someone's very soul that's what I hate
about leftism I hate I hate that it
crushes the soul the human spirit it's
not for lack of compassion for those in
need but precisely because of it as my
point I don't want to see the strong
having their goodness stolen from the
weather its points at a soccer game
whether it's that middle-class family
who deserve to get into a home that they
saved for and by proxy by the way stolen
from all the people who could be blessed
by it that's it something that's
important strength people who are strong
can bless other people whether it's
financially let's think about this
someone who's blessed financially
intellectually even physically they can
help you move intellectually they can
teach you financially they can be the
ones building wells
so to steal it from them is to steal the
blessing from everyone who was blessed
through them and what do you do you hand
it to the chronically weak to the
chronically envious the left wants you
to think that they have a corner on
compassion they don't they're not
capable of it because they're followers
and they're weak they don't have a
corner on compassion they have a corner
on Envy and you see it right now with
Google you see it right now culturally
with this kickback and the babies being
put to bed who are screaming their
plaintive wails don't give in to it
don't buy into it if you give in to it
if you give in to the left catering to
your envy you give in you're already a
shadow of your potential doomed to a
life of weakness dominated by envy get
stronger today tomorrow and the next day
however you can I want to see more of
you out there you like Samantha bee of
course not because you actually made it
to this end card you are a miracle of
the Internet I would say subscriber hit
the notification button but I don't
really know what that means on YouTube
you might not get notified anyway but
you can join up at laterthe credit com /
mug club that's monk with this wonderful
hand etched mug and you get to watch not
only clips but the full one-hour Daily
Show every single day that was redundant
because I said daily but every single
day we're gonna keep it anyway because
we shoot these end cards a whole lot in
one afternoon we're scraping the bottom
of the barrel with this one